in this part of steinfort cs20 for
double you
a machine ring big crash course he
won it alka built the choice of graf
representation
so awake component of van graaf forum
network zo
network is composed of the touch of a
project offers first we go object so
rank  first him his score
referred to as distress en de war teeth and
then went corrections or somewhere between
them
cold links of somewhere and then the entire
system the
entire domain offers a chorus network or
off
youzhny for note reviews the words the
letter capital  en ears capitol i am and
then for ages
wie via a usually using doe de leads
there don't just look so the grafi
is then compost of a set of notes and in
a set of ages
what is import and horticulture the grace is
that count sara can  a link
minute detail can take collect judges
and could i am broom not smoothies da
pear serve how rich and t people we are
the
relationships gone and weed each other
like and take molecule bad protei  ns
and build an airport base and which
produce internet offers you golden
look at what is the structure of the
network what is that other lang with in
articles representation in olies cases
we go another long with the mighty
kolere presentation how the chinese that
so a machine ring of gorinchem
will be able to make predictions then
offers die snood and
correspond to actors correspond to
people horebeek corresponds to molecules
like product of kors
choosing a proper krater presentation is
at the imports zo food supply igz of
people
week and connecting the video  is that
workum the cheddar en horrificness a
professional network
glamor week silly think so insect of
in die jones en Koningen dan bij such
sexy relationships
but then be be creating gassector
twerk hear for example i became a set
of thank'ee pepers
week a  rabbit the broom sedation switch
pepper site which
other pepper what exemple fireworks
to connect and based on whether they is
du  s a words in the title the the
quality or underlined network in the
underline the presentation my b-max
will be the gryce or what the zero there and
where the links are
is with the imports as many new ones
to dataset
at weenie to decide how  we are going to
design the underlying graf
what will be the object of interest distress
and what we offer relationships between
them what will be the edges and the
choice of the proper network
representation of all we do menorah
someone problem die te strangle term in our
ability  to use networks
successful in some cases
there will be a unique to a binary
know dory prix are the is a problem
this domain as a degree while other
cases that series presentation made by no
means bmi to and the wifi as a your
newsletter a john jackd
how do you get that term in the nature of the
questions will be able to study and the
nature of the predictions
wifi  co-creating graphs harry woutersen
concept in diever and type's of graphs
can't do this this week and create from
daten
first five armies system for you
directed and an director
crossride from direct graphs left
that that to that direct opinion that the
year your shoe before  modeling symmetry
hear reciprocal relationships like
collaboration friendship and interaction
between proteins and soul and wine
directed
relationships are captured by directed
links magic castle direction guessing
source and has a destination
de nut bye bye en op and is appels of
the strypes of links
green the real  world to be fun chose
financial transactions of following kon
tweeter became
izak source en this destination
de second bite of congress de piano went
to them talk about
is dat as cradle and create it to
director graff
than one week and talk about the 0 button
anode  the greek
en de noot die gray is simply the number
of pages on jason torquay we nou so far
envoys d  e need one in the sample is the
complaint for that I quickly have the degree i
simply the i simply the carriage over the
degryse or for the need in the network
and you for wifi work the site something there
would be twice
number of pages the  wider by the number
of in our internet the reasoned there
is this number two is
beacause my weather computing' degrees of
denans each en jets counted whitey checkpoint
of the of jets jets counter cross the greenhouse
the edge restaurant points and travel guide
side advice
that sometimes  for something that no inca's there 5 cf
then once all those three or toe
toodle-oo the need for that video of
tunnel beacause above endpoints parties
to say no the sith for direct
map indirectly becomes the network study
stingers immediately in those three and  old diri
mini i in the great number of somewhere
pointing towards an old for zampano
itself is in the greek to
en die al 3d warm white is the number of
further spawn think outside how to see it
from the
from the distress
we had the popular  e typographic
archer that is to leave the tissues and
nothing functioning national in that friend
to do something cool about that party the power
and by party graphic degree generally
of notes of to the frame types were
draws us oil in offer the other pipe
or needs but  not to each other
so for x number and by martijn de graaf
in his degree where notes commit split
into two partitions and the de irons om
league from left to right partition
and never insight the sympathetic lonely
anger of by de graaf's party dat natural
eerko experiences
his digicorders also linked to de pepers
always did
hackers linked to the movies da peer
die user make up for the beauty d reed by
worth
come and soul and so hear
customers collect by a product that will be by
party grafi at the can him a set of
customers a set of project and die link
customer to the product shaper just
after he gives the fine de
werk part time work werk mieke news of the
fine bone china for this kind of project
network with which can create collect
about collaboration networks on
armonico rating network and the areas as
follows of
this have by partisan council I take
a project is by part 1 degree do your
village the left side or to the rights and
me and my project not busy you oil
use the notes from one side in my
project sjeng kraft
and the weihai rabbit balance is to say a
nu crete connection between a pair of
note if they have at least one take
rings can so lisa oriental and design tv
peppers am busy are they on  u
create a cooperation on record tall ship
crashed where we connect a pair of
porters seemed about that least one pepper in
bowl of soup vaporize
want to win streak over that player
solder connected with each other
for collect series enter that still
coursera paper series no time  between
them but for use on device into cold
were peper solderie salim pikmin de
picos de kool it there is
this paper geer en in analog sled you
can also be us create a project  of
this by party network to the to derive
insight and then i hoe
million it on a a grave like this and
if a set by party the count care
that party the count hifi don't say a word the
price of somewhere mary is popular
specially gives also  not type's or never
nice news there are product users and
movies or terrace and papers om in such
a kind of other interesting' point
pole gracie's
hadouir called his the
de and called his tim graphs is an
interest in question
why i do that patient a  wire is to
the present it
who de anna jason symetrix sorry
sanchioni who for the team and to
direct it for the santo count in this
case to and never in all case for your we
create a square matrixx magixx matrixx
him die binary twosome politics and 3  sub
zero a man and essential to a three
of matrixx ai jamie be set to one of no
time they are connected to be set to
zero
has der noot connects or there is barely
when rook connect it straight from a
tree warm
rowan column toe de rizwan and do pico
studies connected to warm up to go to
call a warm biologist hermela something like mr
and jason symmetric or aan directed
grasaar naturally symmetry
love graphic direct thinking
matrixx monki symmetry quick as to
left too hot who goes but when  what
delusion that is mark lean back so far
asylum to and in similaire who can
games inc or
needed degrees and simply cashier girl
akros hear that monroe
scratch my column or the
grave acheson symetrix as far as possible
or thinking stingy on major  sarah jason
week and just go and some the basic to
the number of warns
number of other distress that's new note
first connector to dc's for
hands straight the grass for direct grass
next needles those three candies all
about columns and sometimes about dandruff or  the
grasse agency mitex if if he had to
respond
who the this file station
whiteboard and consequence of ria for
an app works is the derek voice is purple
so this most  if you would look at the
door
jason symetrix series an agency measurement
safari and for the network where basic now
for 3 euros
psychology each have their own white
to that and otherwise the cell design team
you gave the strypes of soupers purple and
metric became true  there are large parts
on the matrixx that there empty that there is something
about and that selection board and consequence
for the properties of this may exactly
because there extremely
sparse to show you honey suckle right
you gave a network to never never and
the maxim degree of final
the number of connections to also quarrels
and meines long
because you can connect to aleah and
basically le connect through noise other
distress served network
so for i simple has yo very young and
you think about call
social network the maxim those three
that you well cooked  the maximum number of
friends I am
neither and ria bridge in my in the cloud
we would call that mobile phone a wheel and frijns
drives all number of friendship is much
much more
so that smi  ts the led interview my
social network
is extreme is purple enter will that a lot
of other
thief and types of network china power
greek internet connection science
collaboration an email graff and so on
and so forth
hair extreme is purple i have a rigid
die  are all ramsteijn
may be up to abdullah handshake so what is
the class i wish the consequences that der
that underline kj are symmetric of
her extreme lease horse so who should
take called are the matrixx if it
dance matrixx with your perusing reaper
are this if there  sparse matrixx
dare to other ways to the praise and
bury what is simply to the present it
as a engine ist simply as a list of
ends but this is a representation
that is quite popular in deep learning
frameworks because i can simply present
it as a tool  those people and matrixx the
problem of the fair percentage is that
this is vineyard matter and you can about
graff manipulation to and i can
alice is on the count
because i and comp  uting' of that guyot
van die me need is never region in this
case a much better way presentation for
a graph analytic and manipulation is the
national of jason ca
end of jesus elystar good big air
easy work does not belong here for large
and spice networks and  addresses soloist
simple as a ghost you pyrite called
entrepreneurs or a new note
will you can a coffee that for evernote
you simply disturb as much as or something
takers so a ruse or emergency that the
that the kimono disconnect it has the
free to the judge
you could  store nemer is the free
connector that also stores well above the
old king neighbors
as we as a team coming neighbors base
and the direction of the edge
and the last import and tinka because to
mention time is that or cost this graff
can grab art and
patch attributes  the show notes
agence if ever entire gras can there
really reboots on properties attached to
the sofa recycle on edge kan ma great
hall beaches understand sees the relationship
with him on ranking I think have
type'
could not no mass whether this is a
frame animal belong to the zippers
animosity waste die stress led cbs the
relationships and agents can him that
at now that friend ty sup property slide
lapwing savoy cabbage something something duration
for  is apple
distress can her properties in is bizarre
people it could be hey
gender interest location in sola die van
distress that is there can make up perhaps it
is know you can I know a formula 1
other properties of de of the chemical
could be  presented as a tribute of the
know and of course of so in tire graff
scan goes features hear
rt neighborhood beast om the properties of the
underlying object de the graph a
structure they kill link so
what is wrong is the de Graaf driver that
concealer in  its knowledge as the
topology need huh josh body tissot so
the attributes to do it really
adjustment mention some of these
properties can actually be presented and
account that jason symetrix is wise of
e  r is barely property so features like
know
can simply be present at team dhd
session I cut riders environment of jason
symetrix to be binary
who have channel jason symetrix admit
rio regions where the strand or the
connexxion correspond the simply to
the value in the en  tricks on tour for a
more strongfeeling
we would receive louis rail wire for someone
in friar the love the reconnection
with go swing tom ran on if
another import is one thing we
created graphic he also looks us in
think about distress creation itself
for you will reign no the previous saw his
curse in which report degree of need for
i close to free to dairy on her
simply
correspond to the rhine sad om de the
islands of the o'jays and symetrix
and in some cases the mix i create a
trouble like again via l'amour type
ledgers
between a pair of note some times vetch
vetch single van must the joke if there
know the grave where that a three dogs
matrixx count the number of areas  but
sometimes i want to the present
ref in that video lies seperately de
cosby's agence minecraft diferent
properties in the frame te dan an
attribute
upwards to the cerf looks as we as
multicraft quite frankly in nature for in shampoo
leave you think about form codes
transactions
work and who should be deeper transactions
between a pair of fast week and
excel present if there should i get
off as cradle and the grass high itunes
along to talk about
the notion of could i team i in adsense
weather the graphically connected home  with
connector and graphically connected' has
en per or noot in indian count kimbie
can be connected via separate already long
particles on the canal barely that
sperry color graphically connected'
where lysander graphically wet connect
xs series connector component
this is one connect it  component sec and
connector component am absolutely
connect the component de zero dough you
must be isolated note this is
also chorus in the knee we  that change
in grass and the what is interest in this
notion irish
that my ing magrav stands there
for such a police connected and look at
what is the structure of the other lanka
jason symetrix wants is blank
diagonal structure where basic edition
would like the  kiss compost of toe
component dan mini have blood and
structure
where the ends only kobe team de
in cybus a correct component and
there is no
ends in that affair a horse with the
less there is located between rijn and
blue
part of de graaf de 0  -button
connectivity
wholesale jane er rises to direct the
count
who's [ __ ] building home
that connectivity strong and the
connectivity but who click connector
direct draht you see pia dig the
molar connected in
miss mieke north direction dust that
somewhere like stream that digs connected
connect your hearing aid history
for this a see-saw note derek
see immediately the best between de zo die
smits de berg as to x is that  direct
pass from for is apples from 0 to note
ii if we bother mode be back to know
they leave the count is current that is
correct
what you sometimes agree to is that we can talk
about notion of current that connect the
component where the current that  connect
components are sets of no tenth degree
size what ever i know the in this kind
can who sits each other piano
via-direct best for is only in
this case no problem ebn see for emma the
current that connector component who chose
the jonas  cycles so week and me for my
idol week and who sits a ladder that I
simply airshows to direct graff
measuring devices connect the component a
game to cycles
to a series 0
so that is the discussion of the
count représentations to that and
scale week and create  gravel and
audiodata in die snatcher i first part
about machine in which we graphs and at
yes applications in use cases acta
does need line of and slime link on a
flower
machine teaching audience fantastic and
then be discussed the choice of
graaf representation in terms of direct
teeth straight the grass by martijn de
graaf
know it to know the graafschap jason
symmetrical
as we lessons sam met de finish from
craft your i like
the connectivity en of grafts week
collective die flow connectivity
if we like the notion of nuts that three
think very much